[Musique]
la ministre chargée de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes de la diversité
de l'égalité des chances et venue en
visite à La Réunion c'est par un échange
avec les élèves du lycée professionnel
vubel dans les hauts de Saint-Paul qui
s'appelle l'envirum a débuté sa première
journée
au programme Culture de l'égalité lutte
contre le harcèlement et sensibilisation
pour prévenir les violences conjugales
et intrafamiliales autour d'ateliers
mais également éducation à la sexualité
et à la vie affective le respect pour
la fin poster la question te sens-tu
encore un homme
c'est pas vraiment respecté ce soit dans
le collège ou soit des réseaux sociaux
même dans le monde en fait c'est pas à
me respecter dans beaucoup de pays et
selon moi c'est vraiment quelque chose
de grave je comprendrais jamais pourquoi
si on serait une personne l'homme et la
femme ne serait pas égaux et là sur
l'expérience
dans l'après-midi la ministre s'est
rendue à lamafar l'association maison de
la famille où elle a annoncé le
déploiement du pack nouveau départ sur
le territoire
alors en fait ce pack il permet
justement d'accompagner des femmes
lorsqu'elles sentent qu'elles peuvent
être en danger chez elle
et qu'elle prenne conscience de cela et
cela peut même être avant qu'elle porte
plainte c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
le moment je sens que ça va pas aller et
comme pardon comme souvent quand on a
vécu comme ça sous la coupe d'un
conjoint violent on est très souvent
humilié
on sait plus où on en est on est
complètement détruite et c'est très
difficile de pouvoir justement partir et
quand je dis partir cela ne veut pas
forcément dire quitter le domicile mais
ça veut simplement dire quitter son
conjoint voilà donc j'en profite pour
dire que ce dispositif il peut
s'appliquer quel que soit les
circonstances que la femme quitte le
domicile ou qu'elle y reste et à ce
moment-là c'est les conjoint qui est
éloigné mais en fait à ce moment-là
lorsqu'elle se dit qu'elle est peut-être
en danger et que il faut qu'elle faut
qu'elle fasse quelque chose et bien
l'idée c'est qu'elle puisse dire cela à
un certain nombre d'acteurs et donc la
liste n'est pas précisée justement pour
que avoir le plus de chance possible que
cette parole puisse être entendue donc
ça peut être une association qui peut
recueillir ces confidences et donc
entendre la situation dans laquelle elle
se trouve donc une association mais ça
peut être aussi un médecin ça peut être
un avocat ça peut être un gendarme ça
peut être un policier ça peut être aussi
le maire d'une petite commune un juge
éventuellement et donc une fois que ce
cette personne
est au courant de la situation de cette
dame et si bien sûr si elle le souhaite
et bien il va contacter un interlocuteur
unique à la caisse d'allocations
familiales et cette interlocuteur unique
la caisse d'allocation familiale va
déclencher pour cette victime les aides
dont elle peut avoir besoin
comme dans un système de priorité et
donc cela peut être une allocation comme
le RSA cela peut être
une mesure de Retour à l'Emploi ou de
formation cela peut être un
accompagnement psychologique cela peut
être
aussi une aide pour le pour faire garder
son enfant et cela peut-être si besoin
un hébergement d'urgence voilà
l'essentiel c'est que on réponde le
mieux possible à ses besoins elle s'est
ensuite rendue à l'unité psychotromae
SMR
autre temps fort de cette visite la
réunion publique de présentation du plan
ministériel pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes à la préfecture
l'occasion pour le conseil départemental
de rappeler que le thème des violences
intrafamiliales fait partie des axes
prioritaires de sa mandature au
quotidien nos services sont mobilisés
nous
notamment des travailleurs sociaux en
quasium de police et de gendarmerie 13
personnels dédiés à l'accueil à
l'accompagnement à l'écoute le dialogue
avec les personnes victimes de violence
nous avons aussi tous les services
d'information préoccupants qui
accompagne les familles mais surtout les
enfants parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
il y a des violences envers des adultes
et souvent ce sont les femmes qui
subissent ces violences et il y a aussi
parmi les victimes des enfants et donc
ce travail qui est réalisé en lien avec
les autorités judiciaires et important
je dois dire aussi que il y a un travail
qui est venu avec les associations sur
tout le territoire réunionnais et je
vais terminer en parlant notamment le
travail qui est réalisé dans les
collèges par l'Éducation nationale
auprès des collégiens mais pas que les
collégiens ça se passe depuis les écoles
en passant par les collèges les lycées
où il y a des actions de sensibilisation
d'information pour prévenir les
violences
la Réunion et le deuxième territoire à
expérimenté le dispositif du pack
nouveau départ il sera déployé à partir
de juin
[Musique]